se avecinan nuevas alianzas tras
conocerse los resultados de la primera
vuelta de las elecciones en chile las
dos orillas del espectro político la
izquierda representada por gabriel boric
y la ultraderecha por jose antonio kast
buscarán coaliciones que les permitan
ganar la segunda vuelta el 19 de
diciembre con el fracaso de los partidos
tradicionales en los comicios cobra
especial interés quien se llevará los
cerca de 900 mil votos que obtuvo el
político independiente franco parisi
boris que ha apostado por un discurso
más moderado ya le hizo un guiño a sus
seguidores
queremos hablar con usted y queremos
decirle queremos decirle a todos quienes
le temen a la delincuencia que vamos a
estar llevamos a estar con ustedes por
su lado cast afirmó que en los próximos
27 días buscará unir proyectos sin bajar
el tono a sus acusaciones contra el
candidato izquierdista personas son las
que tienen que elegir un modelo y van a
hacer dos modelos de sociedad distinto
un modelo que tiene el totalitarismo y
que nos va a llevar al fracaso y nuestro
modelo que quiere la libertad nos va a
llevar al desarrollo eso lo va a decidir
la gente a pesar de que la ultraderecha
y su espacio en la cámara de diputados
con 15 escaños por primera vez desde el
regreso de la democracia y la alianza
pro dignidad de boris se quedó con 36
escaños ninguno de sus partidos tendrá
una mayoría en el senado donde se
renovaron 27 de los 50 escaños se
repitió la polarización que marcó las
elecciones sin una mayoría clara entre
la izquierda y la derecha dejando un
escenario aún más incierto para quien
llegue al palacio de la moneda el
próximo marzo